les réactions des politiques notamment
les réactions
gouvernementales dans les premiers jours
les premières heures qui ont suivi les
événements
2005 et celles qui ont suivi les
événements en 2023 sont radicalement
différentes Nicolas Sarkozi euh et un
certain nombre de ses conseillers
parfois même d'ailleurs contre d'autres
membres du gouvernement n'ont pas du
tout jouer l'apaisement dans les jours
qui ont suivi la mort des deux enfants
en 2005 euh
pour revenir sur ce qui a été dit à
l'époque mais le politique n'a pas
tempéré n'a pas eu à cœur en tout cas de
tempérer même si d'autres membres du
gouvernement défendaient une autre ligne
à commencé par Monsieur bag ministre de
des villes sans doute en 2023 vous vous
souvenez sans doute que il y a eu
unanimité à la fois d'ailleurs dans la
représentation parlementaire et au
gouvernement pour condamner le geste
policier c'est c'est important de le
souligner parce que ça n'a eu aucun
effet sur les comportements que nous
avons observé ça soulligne à quel point
il y a une fraction de la jeunesse qui
est particulièrement
sensible aux
actions des forces de l'ordre là aussi
police nationale jendarmerie nationale
police municipale he c'est important euh
et qui n'est pas du tout sensible à ce
qui peut être dit par les représentants
politiques
c'est pour moi c'est un un phénomène qui
signe je dirais la distance
considérable qui sépare qui sépare ces
de mondes